c'est un moment un peu particulier pour
Emmanuel Rollin et Arnaud Cormier dans
quelques jours ces deux ivelinois
prendront la route avec leur Peugeot 205
direction le Maroc pour un projet
humanitaire mais si la carrosserie du
véhicule est flambant neuve à
l'intérieur tout reste à faire dans
notre projet on a des passages de dune
et pour les passages de dunes il faut
qu'on puisse dégonfler les roues il faut
qu'on puisse dégonfler jusqu'à 0 0,5
barres et inversement forcément qu'on
revient sur les pistes on regonfle à
deux barres donc on a un système avec un
compresseur l'inttérieur de la voiture
qui nous permet de de gérer le gonflage
des pneus pour permettre ça on a des
pièces sur ce flexible qui est relié à
notre compresseur et qui va être relié
directement au rou des manœuvres
mécaniques bien spécifiques pour un
trajet qui est tout autant notre projet
c'est de participer à une organisation
qui s'appelle le Duster RCE qui est une
organisation sociale pour aller
distribuer des fournitures scolaires
dans des village au fin fond de l'atlase
au Maroc je dis bien au fin fond de
l'Atlas parce queon est vraiment dans le
sud du Maroc dans les montagnes si le
projet était prévu bien avant le séisme
au Maroc l'association a réorganisé son
trajet pour s'approcher des zonees
sinistré l'organisation dustraist a déjà
fait la semaine dernière l'intégralité
du tracé en terme de sécurité tout est
tout a été validé grâce à la solidarité
des ivelinois et des entreprises locales
le véhicule a pu être rénové la
concrétisation de plusieurs mois de
travail pour ses passionnés d'automobile
avoir un but
de pouvoir mélanger ça avec aussi un
goût de l'aventure d'aller faire des
dunes dans le désert c'est quand même
quelque chose d'assez sympathique à
faire départ prévu le 19 octobre si vous
aussi vous souhaitez participer à ce
projet l'association est toujours à la
recherche de don